well mr speaker we we condemn the  callous behavior of piano  and i think and i think that it is  i think that it is i think that it is no  way  to treat hard-working  employees and i can tell him that we  will not sit by mr speaker because uh  because under section 194 of the trades  union and labor relations act of 1992 it  looks to me mr speaker as though the  company concerned has broken the law and  we will be taking action therefore and  we will we will be encouraging uh  workers themselves to take action under  the 1996 employment rights act both acts  mr speaker passed by conservative  governments  and  and if the company is found guilty uh  then they face fines running into  millions of pounds mr speaker and in  addition uh we will be taking steps to  protect all mariners who are working in  uk waters and ensure that they are all  paid the living wage mr speaker